but you know just as well as well online
content can just be as easily stolen as
well yeah I've had a lot of [ __ ] stolen
man law I guess was a big coat yeah I
mean that was a whole team man that's
that's a two-hour story and it's all you
get the sparknotes just what exactly
happened on that oh here's what happened
I was out with Duval doing some college
days mm-hmm and the video was getting
some good Steam online on worldstar in
other places and getting millions of
views and I was doing with this guy
Derek Evans he's from Nashville he and I
were doing this man called thing and we
were just man should never do this then
we inserted traumatization act out and
those act outs was where people you know
on top of the laws and then it became
one of those things where I say on
Twitter what you think which I got for
me today suggestions take those
suggestions up so it became a very
interactive thing um I talked to Duval
by doing for uh appearing in the sketch
like you know like how I'm appearing on
your podcast right oh yeah we'll do this
and cool like three months passes by and
I get like phone call I get message
email people start sending me stuff
that's coming out I was like hey man
they're shooting this show up here y'all
you got a TV show on MTV in like Wichita
my and my homeboy in New York like oh
yeah oh yeah congratulations y'all show
got picked up like what you talked about
and man I look up online and the the
show has clearly copied the sketch
verbatim like it wasn't uh always
similar no no the exact sketch the exact
dramatization they copied the format and
then they started adding other people
didn't open it up and made it not less
of an urban thing and made it just a
broader perspective approach on MTV so I
call you know friends got an attorney
filed an injunction against Viacom so
right after that ideas [ __ ] black girls
say that went viral so weirdly enough I
start getting your emails from MTV
different networks and so MTV must mean
like hey when you fly you to New York
wanna meet with you blah blah I'm like
okay cool
I'm thinking it's got something to do
with what
the injunction that happened but really
is about this video so we talking
they're like oh we want to do some
programming with you blah blah blah blah
and cool we sitting in a closed
environment like this for people
me-me-me conversation
door opens up lady comes in we're gonna
have to pause right now legals gonna
come in they letting us know you have an
injunction against up here for oh no we
thought you know didn't you know
and so legal comes in he had his whole
conversation about how how does this go
away
he started giving me opportunity
presenting opportunity opportunity well
you know when you have an issue with
Viacom you know we can't do anything
with your Comedy Central we can't do
anything with you abt can't do anything
at you at this so you have to you know
sign a waiver to remove the injunction
but we want to do things which is we
want to get you involved in this show
and this show and this show and this
project and I'm like alright do I try
and fight Goliath
that's what I should've did oh and I
kind of pushed it in was like you know
what this gonna be [ __ ] up the
[ __ ] didn't call back to the H
and say hey um they stole my [ __ ]
show which I do and the whole crew got
our attorneys and everybody was like hey
man this how we do but see this is what
happened when you're a young boy you
trying on my cue to myself I'm in here
he got [ __ ] intimidated see he should
have called Nat Turner boom Ali Siddiq
yeah that's that's what I've been
dealing with my whole time if that be
brothers show oh so you want to fight
him so would you yeah what did you
settle like what a settle manner being
um two things happen one day no giving
us like right at six thousand dollars
for the whole thing nothing all day just
as a piece just for like hey you know so
this is it work gave us some bread
six grand TV show it was [ __ ] for the
whole day
Wow promises and some other [ __ ] mm-hmm
so you got money and then promises
nothing legal nothing on paper nothing
written down not one attorney dis
muhfucka Wow head manager at the time
all right P he r.i.p know you had a
friend your frat brothers part of the
squad cavalry he was like he was like
Billy listen listen to me I know you
want to fight these people you just got
to be smart you know I skipped a whole
nother part of the story I didn t so i
did i did i did get getting get into a
trippy why's me and i'll go on of course
first thing i do I call Duvall no
response no answer I get on Twitter and
um John Stoll mushy blah blah
[Music]
he says you miss pac-man guess what
you're doing is what you want to do you
won't do it this way minam and it was
one thing I learned from that it's like
he pick and choose your battles
differently okay it's one thing I could
tell you was like you know in in
television in Hollywood it doesn't work
the way the street work the way you
think it does
it's is different it's it's a different
process it's a different beast it's a
different animal because everybody feel
like they wanna be safe so if you would
have said a X Y Z and then we would have
put the streets on it then it had been
it had been a different situation you
see how when somebody is slapped drink
and then the streets call then all of a
sudden they they thought of festivity
throwing a party for Drake I was on the
same for that's laughter and then
streets streets mean a lot o you put
what energy yeah streets me in a lot
still my [ __ ] show and watch
what happened
okay but it is Billy from the streets
Chattanooga's he got people he got
people you ain't you probably not from
the street but it's a my [ __ ] with you
and I'm here you called me yeah it like
this why planning for your neighborhood
I'll give up he with the street I see
one Encinas is when you become accessory
to salts and batteries right there
I knew all right I knew if I call him is
dead ain't that ain't gonna be a meeting
at all
it'd be somebody just getting set on
fire some trash cans getting through to
some windows so some people getting beat
up yeah
in it and and there's one thing I had to
learn it was like you know it's a
different way I probably it's a
different way of dealing with this okay
I you know to where the fingers ain't
gonna solve it being angry gonna solve
it he's just understanding how Hollywood
works and that was my first lesson on
Hollywood 101 link hey what did happen
good out of it
[Music]
high breath